[Music]
[Applause]
hey let me make a smooth segue to Zach
Kiefer
Zach covers the Colts and the NFL for
the athletic and the host of the Andrew
Luck podcast it's a six uh part series
six episodes of luck on the athletic
football show feed or wherever you
listen to your podcast
how did you come up with the uh the
thought of doing this whether you were
going to have any cooperation with
Andrew Luck
that's a heck of a segue Dan
um yeah great question
um why now right like why do this
project
um and at first I kind of resisted it I
wasn't ready to dive back in I lived all
of this covering the Colts the last
couple years but for a couple of reasons
one
he's sort of like this mysterious figure
in Indianapolis he lives five minutes
from the team facility the Specter of
Andrew Luck still hangs over this
franchise in a way where you know you go
to Philip Rivers you go to Carson Wentz
you go to Matt Ryan like they haven't
found the next guy and he's only 32
years old and and there's a lot of
what-ifs and to be honest when you dig
into it for a lot of reasons I think
it's one of the more interesting stories
we've had in the NFL in a long time it's
it's incomplete and it's mysterious and
it's surprising and it's
it's just fascinating on a lot of levels
what role does Luck play in the the
mystery here of not just disappearing
but not really commenting on
disappearing
yeah he's he's almost like the like the
Bigfoot in this city like
if you go back it's it's impossible to
understate like how big of a decision it
was for Jim Mercy to move on from Peyton
Manning in 2012 and that's one of the
early episodes it's like that just
wasn't ever supposed to happen and it
did if you're going to move on from
Peyton Manning you move on for the next
Peyton Manning right in a lot of ways
and and then he was done when he was 29
years old and he walked away 15 days
before the season like I remember
looking at that at that guy that night
looking in his face and thinking what
happened like how did we get here and
and that's what we try to answer like
how does the best quarterback prospect
since John Elway end up walking away
before he's 30 years old and what
happened to him since
have you talked to luck
yes
um we caught up he's done no interviews
since he retired he's like a ghost like
I said
um we've stayed in touch we met we had
coffee for an hour and a half all off
the Record so I will honor that he's not
quoted you can imagine my oh
disappointment with that
um but um he thought about participating
which would have been a big deal it
would have been the first time he's
talked since he retired he ultimately
declined but to some degree it's almost
better that he's not in the podcast
because so many people around him
tell the stories that we've never heard
what were the warning signs that we
should have seen
yeah that's a great question that's um
that's into episodes three and four
well I'll go back to Stanford so his
first start as a quarterback David
Shaw's his offensive coordinator in his
first play he scrambles out of the
pocket instead of ducking out of bounds
like a lot of quarterbacks he drives his
throwing shoulder into the safety gets
two yards
and he runs off the field and Shaws live
it and luck says I know I know I know
but I just had to do it I just had to
get one hidden coach that's how he
played like that's how he played the
rest of his career and
and there was a lot of joy to his game
early I mean he was running straight
into linebackers and then picking them
up off the field right getting sacked by
defensive lineman and saying great hit
like these Defenders thought this was a
mind game like he was just different
but that beating that physical
punishment he took and the fact that the
Colts never got him a good offensive
line
the the signs were there I remember so
many hits he would take the the Press
Box which is the Press Box would just
gasp like you just don't see
quarterbacks take those kind of hits
there was one game he took a shot to his
ribs and it lacerated his kidney which
is an accident that usually happens when
you're in a car crash and he woke up the
next day and he was peeing blood so the
warning signs were certainly there
yeah I I I look at it and I don't know
if he's ever pointed fingers here
whether and you can't say this if he
said it privately off the Record but
you know the snowboarding accident
um the way he played yes they didn't
protect him and I used to rail on the
Colts it was like you know you got to
protect him but he wasn't protecting
himself
and I don't think he's ever pointed any
fingers of blame
um or has he that maybe I've missed here
yeah no that's that's a big part of this
like no they didn't protect him but he
played like a linebacker and he's a
tough big dude right he could have
played tight end could have played
linebacker but like you can't do that
and so I have teammates that are saying
you know like every time he took a hit
like we cringed like we knew if he goes
down if the season's over and there's a
really revealing moment in the podcast
where I asked David Shaw and he's really
close to luck to this day one of the few
people that's really inside that Circle
and I said
did the Colts protect Andrew Luck the
right way did they build around him the
right way and Shaw says and he's a coach
for 20 years he says that's the most
loaded question I've ever been asked in
my life
and then he answered me and he said
during those early years in Indy he
would ask luck and Landry would never
publicly
criticized anybody that just wasn't his
thing but privately with Shaw Shaw would
be like what do you need man he's like I
need a running back like they had they
went five years without a hundred yard
rushing five years and he needed an
offensive line so it's twofold Andrew's
not absolved of blame in this and then
the series gets into that I mean he
played Reckless football and he played
and he played a really dear price
he had the foot ankle injury a week
before like wait have I guess did that
speed up the process of him saying you
know I just don't want to go through
this anymore or what role did that play
that's the weirdest thing in all this
like could I be honest like nobody
retires from a calf injury like what
like this dude made it back from
shoulder hell like his his throwing
shoulder he played on for three years
the labrum was torn like that's serious
pain he played through a lacerated
kidney and beat the best defense in
football one year and a calf injury is
what does it
but you know that's really what episode
six is about is like after the shoulder
and after he made it back everything was
different he saw the game differently
and and I think when he looked ahead and
he saw more rehab and more missed time
and More Hell which he'd lived through
I think he chose his mental health above
above everything else and it's an
extremely polarizing decision in this
city to this day
how is he viewed
better now
people have gotten over it now the
feedback from from this podcast has
stirred that back up I mean this is a
guy that retired 15 days before the
season opener the Colts didn't have a
plan
that night when schefter had the report
and he's on the sidelines and it breaks
during a pre-season game they started
booing him it's surreal yeah the face of
the franchise the guy you moved on from
Peyton Manning for is booed off the
field they need to get him back to Lucas
Oil Stadium and they need to celebrate
him the right way and I think Jimmer
said the owner wants to do that
but
like I said there's this Specter I mean
this guy lives five minutes from the
team facility and when I met with him
you know we had this great conversation
I remember looking at him and thinking
you're still 32 years old like you could
go play tomorrow and he's not going to
he's not going to come back I never
thought that but
it's just really strange that this
unfolded the way it did and
um it just kind of feels unfinished in a
lot of ways
the role of being a dad
what role did that play in all of this
yeah
he essentially became a full-time dad
you know imagine walking away from
football which is a 12 hours a day job
every day of the year right and then
they have a baby a couple months later
so he's really throwing himself into
that and we're starting to see him come
out publicly a little bit more I think
there was and this is my word I think
there was a little bit of Shame on his
part the way his retirement happened
when it happened we didn't see him he
was like a ghost for like two and a half
years I would get text messages and
people would would say I saw him at the
grocery he's alive I saw him at this
coffee shop like it was like Bigfoot and
he's starting to come out a little bit
more in a little bit more I think he's
at peace with everything it was hard at
first though why did he why did he stay
in Indianapolis
great question he loves it here he loves
it here
um
his wife has a great job uh they love
they love the food they love the people
they love the fact that he can sort of
blend in a little bit people don't bug
him when we had coffee you know a couple
people double you know double take like
is that Andrew Luck is that really him
and they would come up to the table and
he was great he was great with them so
um I think he's comfortable here but
isn't that telling I mean you walk away
from a team at 29 and
you stay in the city and not just that
you live a couple minutes from the team
facility
great stuff Zach good luck with it
thanks Dan that's uh Zach Kiefer he
covers the Colts and the NFL for the
athletic and uh get all six episodes of
luck on the athletic football show feed
or wherever you listen to podcast